قررت الحكومه الكنديه حضر تطبيق تيك توك
المملوك لشركه صينيه في كافه الاجهزه
والانظمه التابعه لها مبرره قرارها بمخاوف
امنيه بشان جمع واستخدام التطبيق بيانات
شخصيه للمستخدمين بما ينتهك الخصوصيه
ويهدد الامن وكان الاتحاد الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده قد اتخذها قرارات
مماثله وسط التصاعد للتوتر مع الصين على
صعد مختلفه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما مدى وجهه الاسباب
التي دعت الحكومتين الكنديه والامريكيه
وهاياكل في الاتحاد الاوروبي لاتخاذ قرار
حظر تطبيق تيك توك على كل الاجهزه
والانظمه التابعه لها واين يمكن ان نضع
قرارات المنع هذه لتطبيق تيك توك في سياق
التوتر المتصاعد بين الصين والولايات
المتحده ودول غربيه اخرى
والى اين يمكن لهذه القضيه ان تتطور في
ضوء الاهميه المتعاظمه للتنافس المحموم
بين القوى العظمى للسيطره على المجال
الافتراضي باشكاله المختلفه
[موسيقى]
ينطوي على مخاطر فيما يتعلق بجمع واستخدام
المعطيات الشخصيه للمستخدمين على نحو
ينتهك الخصوصيه ويهدد الامن هكذا استقرت
صوره تطبيق تيك توك عند عدد من الحكومات
والدوائر الرسميه الغربيه تلك التي لا
تخفي خشيتها المتعاظمه من ان تيك توك لا
يعدو ان يكون حصان ترواد الافتراضي والذي
تخترق به الصين امنه تلك الدول القومي
والاجتماعي
البيت الابيض امهل الدوائر الحكوميه 30
يوما حتى تزيل تيك توك من كل الاجهزه
والنظم التي تستخدمها وكان مجلس النواب
الامريكي دعا في مذكره داخليه المشرعين
وموظفين الى ازاله التطبيق من هواتفهم
واجهزتهم المحموله
وبدورها شهدت مؤسسات تابعه للاتحاد
الاوروبي اهمها مفوضيته ومجلس النواب
الاوروبي التابع له اجراءات لوقف التعامل
مع التطبيق المثير للجدل
وفي رد الفعل الصيني قالت سبيجين للنواشم
تنبالغت في رد فعلها تجاه التطبيق واتهمت
متحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
الولايات المتحده باساءه استخدام سلطه
الدوله لقمع الشركات الاجنبيه
اما لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في مجلس النواب
الامريكي فقد مررت اليوم مشروع قرار يمنح
الرئيس الامريكي صلاحيات جديده لمنع تطبيق
تيك توك وتطبيقات اخرى مملوكه اجنبيا في
الولايات المتحده وفي تصريحات صحفيه اعرب
رئيس اللجنه النائب الجمهوري الذي تقدم
بمشروع القرار عن اعتقاده بان مجلس النواب
سيصوت في المنظور القريب على مشروع القرار
[موسيقى]
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من لندن
الدكتور افضل شريف استاذ او افضل اشرف
عفوا استاذه دراسات الامنيه والعلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه لافرا البريطانيه وينضم
الينا لاحقا من نيويورك الدكتور بيتر مسك
الخبير في امن المعلومات والمحاضر في
اداره الانترنت في كليه الشؤون الدوليه
والعامه بجامعه كولومبيا ابدا معك اذا
الضيفنا من لندن سيد افضل اشرف
هذه الهواجس الامنيه لدى الغرب بالنسبه
لتطبيق تيك توك
كيف تقراها هل هي مبنيه على اساس هل لديها
ما يبررها
اعتقد ان تقييم هذه الامور هو على اساس
انها مبرره وذلك لان كل التطبيقات التواصل
الاجتماعي لديها القدره على
على
طرح شفرات قد تكون مضره تسمح بالدخول الى
الاجهزه
وان تتجاوز اجراءات الحمايه في كل جهاز
لتستخلص معلومات من الجهاز لكن ما هو اكثر
خطوره وجديه من ذلك اي
شفره ضاره في الجهاز ممكن ان تؤثر
بالنظام برمته الذي يرتبط فيه الجهاز او
الهاتف لهذا السبب يتم حظر تيك توك من
الاجهزه التي يستخدمها مسؤولون حكوميون في
الولايات المتحده وكندا اليوم ايضا وكذلك
من قبل
الحكومات الاوروبيه اذا من الاهميه لنا ان
ندرك بان هذا الحظر ليس حظرا
بالنسبه لكثيرين في العالم الغربي يبقى
الامر كما هو معتاد لكن هذه القدره على
طرح شفرات ضاره هي مصدر الخوف
وهاجس الخطر من حق الناس ان يسالوا لماذا
هذا يطبقه على تيك توك وليس على فيسبوك او
تويتر على سبيل المثال اعتقد ان التبرير
التي تقدمها الحكومات المعنيه هو ان
بامكانهم ان
يستحضروا او يستدعوا كبار المسؤولين من
هذه المنظمات ليمثلوا امام الكونجرس فقط
فعلوا ذلك حقيقه في الاشهر القليله
الماضيه للرد على ايه مزاعم بشان
تطبيقاتهم ولكن حتى الان نحن نتحدث عن
تطبيقات غرب غربيه خصوصا تطبيقات صينيه
موجوده في الولايات المتحده ويمكن للرئيس
الامريكي الان حسب مشروع القانون الذي قدم
ان يتصرف كما يراه مناسبا حتى الان ليس
هناك دليل يثبت ان اي خطر قد وقع فعلا انه
تم
الحصول على معلومات معينه اذا القرار مبني
على
مخاوف فقط هل يمكن الوصفه بانه اجراء
وقائي في هذه المرحله
ان هذا سيكون ردا حكيما نعم انتم يحقون في
القول
لا يوجد كثير من الادله
الملموسه على ان تيك توك استخدم تطبيق
لكي
يلحق هذا الضرر لكن الامكانيه موجوده
النقطه الاهم في رايه التي يجب ان ننتبه
اليها هي ان
شركات تطبيقات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
الغربيه يمكن محاسبتها من قبل الحكومه
الامريكيه بينما الشركه الصينيه لن يمكن
محاسباتها اذا ما ثبت وجود خطر ملموس
اعتقد ان هذا هي التبريرات المحتمله لكننا
واضح ايضا لا يمكن
انسى تماما احتمال ان على الاقل لدرجه
معينه ان هذه
القوانين الحظر اجراءات
وراءها
تداعيات
وتنافس اوسع نطاقا اقتصا وسياسيا بين
الصين وبقيه العالم في الواقع
الان انضم الينا من نيويورك ونريد فقط في
البدايه ان نفهم تقنيا اذا كانت هذه
المخاوف الغربيه الامنيه مبرره تقنيا
للاسف نحن لم نسمع سوى شائعات وتعليقات
منقوله
من مصادر حول هذه المخاوف والمخاطر
التقنيه التي
تنشا عن تيك توك ولم نرى اي براهين اي
ادله لا على الورق
ولا في وسائل الاعلام وبالتالي نحن نعتمد
هنا في حكمنا على بيانات وتصريحات من
مسؤولين يرفضون تقديم الادله والبراهين
وفعلا هذا محبط ان نرى هذه الخدمات التي
الكثير منها الشركات
التي ككثير منها في سيليكون فالي
تعاني ثغرات امنيه لا تحترم خصوصيه بيانات
عملائها مره تلو الاخرى
تجرم او تغرم بسبب اختراقات امنيه
ولكن لا تعاقب كما يجب وهنا هنا ياتي
السؤال سيد مسك اذا سمحت لي يعني في
النهايه تطبيق تيك توك يعد من انجح
التطبيقات ان لم يكن انجح
قاطبه يعني في هذا النوع من التطبيقات هل
هنا نتحدث عن غيره تنافسيه
اكثر من شيء اي الى اي حد هذا القرار
جانب اقتصادي ام ان الجانب السياسي
هو الارجح هنا
ان تيك توك ليس لديه هذه السلطه او هذه
صلاحيات التي
حصلتها مجموعات الضغط التي امضت سنوات في
العاصمه واشنطن مقارنه بشركه التكنولوجيه
الكبرى التي صار لديها مجموعات ضغط
واستثمارات استثمارات كبيره في علاقتها مع
الحكومه الامريكيه وغيرها من الحكومات
بينما تيك توك هو حديث العهد وبالتالي
طبعا هذا يلعب ضده فيما يتعلق بالتاثير في
صناعه السياسات بصوره عامه في العالم
وبالتالي من الممكن ان نرى هذه الشركات
الكبيره لا تقف الى جانب التيك توك ولا
تدعمه ولكن بكل صراحه المسؤوليه تقع على
الحكومه الامريكيه وغيرها ايضا الحكومات
الاخرى من اجل صياغه التنظيمات التي
توجه او تدقق في هذه الشركات التي توفر
هذه الخدمات فيما يتعلق باحترام الخصوصيه
وتخزين البيانات فكل هذا القطاع متاخر
اصلا في هذا المجال سيد افضل اشرف يعني
هناك نقطه لافته اذا كان ليس هناك دليل
حقيقي تستند اليه هذه الحكومات الغربيه
سواء امريكا كندا او هياكل في الاتحاد
الاوروبي
فانها اخذت هذا القرار هل هذا يعكس ربما
تقارب بين هذه الدول فيما يتعلق بالصين في
ملفات اخرى هذه الاستراتيجيه التي
اعتمدتها اتجاه تطبيق تيك توك
لم افهم السؤال يمكن اعاده السؤال
التقارب الزمني بين القرارات التي اتخذت
من الدول الغربيه بحق تطبيق التيك توك
وحظره هل ربما يعكس او يشير الى
استراتيجيه غربيه موحده في التعامل مع
الصين تحديدا مع هذا الملف
وايضا يعكس التقارب بين هذه الدول في
ملفات وجوانب اخرى
اعتقد ان الامر يمكن ان ينظر اليه من هذا
المنظور وفي بعض الزوايا هو بالتاكيد كذلك
بالتاكيد الولايات المتحده اوروبا
لديهم تنافس
اقتصادي لكنه ما ينسقان اجراءاتهما فيما
يتعلقوا بالجانب الامني
ولان الجانب الامني هو المحرك الاساسي في
هذه القضيه فان التنسيق يتم من ناحيه
التوقيت الزمني لكن ربما من الافضل ان
نتذكر وقد اشرتم الى ذلك من قبل وهو
الاليات القانونيه هي فقط
تقيدات حتى اللحظه على اجهزه
حكوميه لكن الصكوك القانونيه المطبقه بدات
2020 وفي الايام الاسابيع القليله بدات
تظهر الى سطح اكثر وهناك فقط هنا شكرا فقط
اريد ان الفت الى ما
ذهبت اليه اداره تطبيق تيك توك التي كانت
تفاعلت مع هذه الهواجس والمخاوف الامنيه
الامريكيه والغربيه وقالت انها لن تمتثل
ابدا لاي طلب بمشاركه بيانات المستخدمين
وتصر اداره تيك توك على ان التطبيق لا
يعمل بشكل مختلف عن شركات التواصل
الاجتماعي الاخرى سيد
بيتر مسك اذا
يعني يحتفظ التطبيق الشركه تقول انا ليس
لدينا اي اهداف لا تجسس ولا اختراق امن
وما الى ذلك ما هو الضرر الذي سيلحق بهذه
الشركه جراء تطبيق الحظر عليها
تطبيق شعبي محبوب في العالم الغربي
حيث افتتح وحدات تجاريه في الولايات
المتحده في دول اخرى
وتوسع سريعا في منطقه شرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا وطبعا
هذه الشركه مهتمه في الاعلانات في
[موسيقى]
التربح بالدولار واليورو والجنيه
الاسترليني من خلال الاعلانات والدعايات
للوصول الى الاكبر عدد ممكن من المستخدمين
اذا على الارجح هناك مليارات الدولارات
التي هي الان على المحك نتحدث هنا عن
مردود الدعايات والاعلانات ولكن ايضا
تريد الشركه نظر اليها كما لو انها
بمستواه تويتر ومتى وغيرها من عمالقه
التكنولوجيا وبالتالي هذه ضربه لها علامه
تجاريه ولصمعتها ايضا هل يمكن ان تلتف على
مثل هذه القرارات سيد مسك
تيك توك الان في موقف حرج جدا
هي حاولت ان تقطع العلاقات بين
[موسيقى]
الشركه بوجودها الامريكي والشركه القابضه
الموجوده في الصين وتحاول ان تفصل بينهم
وتقول كل منهما كيان مستقل بحد ذاته على
الاقل في ارتفاعها عن نفسها امام الكونجرس
الامريكي ولكن يبدو ان قطع العلاقه
التجاريه
والتحدث عن نسختين
منفصلتين الناس يحبون تيك توك هو تطبيق
شعبي وبالتالي هناك الكثير من القيمه ولكن
الامور واضحه على ما اعتقد بالنسبه الى
هيكليه الشركه وكيف تبدو للعالم
هل نحن امام اجراء وقائي ام اجراء هجومي
يهدف الى التقليم اذرع
واظافر الصين الافتراضيه
ان شاء الله
حاليا بالتاكيد الامر يقدم كان اجراء
وقائي لانه حظر على
المنصات المملوكه للحكومه بالنسبه لغالبيه
الناس حاليا في كندا وفي الوقت المتحده
وفي بلدان الاتحاد الاوروبي يمكنهم ان
يستخدموا ان يستخدموا تيك توك حاليا
الجانب الاكثر
اهميه وانا اضيف الى نقطه الدكتور مسك
المهمه انها منصه تحظى بشعبيه كبيره وهي
منصه
استطاعت ان تسيطر في مجال استخدامها
الشباب وتتجاوز ربما فيسبوك
والذين التي لا يستخدمها الشباب بشكل كبير
في العالم الغربي لكن الخطر الذي يواجهه
الغرب يقمن في ان الشركات الغربيه مثل
فيسبوك
سمحت وهذا مجرد مزاعم الان بان تستخدم
البيانات لاغراض سياسيه
للتاثير في الانتخابات كما يزعم في
الانتخابات الامريكيه وايضا يزعم ان
اضافه الى تويتر
تستخدمه
المنصاتان
كوسيله للتاثير لصالحي
حكومات اجنبيه اعتقد ان الخوف من عدم
القدره على السيطره على او محاسبه الشركات
التي هي ليست داخل البلدان الغربيه هي
الدافع وراء مثل هذه الخطوه طبعا انا اتفق
مع القول باننا لن نستطيع تحليل هذه
المساله من دون التعامل مع القضيه الاوسع
نطاقا وهي التنافس الاقتصادي والسياسي كما
اوحى بذلك سؤالكم
مسك الحديث عن ربما ايقاف تطبيقات اخرى
يعني هل نحن على وشك وعتاب حرب سيبرانيه
ربما تتجاوز الحرب التقليديه هل فعلا هناك
خوف من اننا نتوجه نحو ذلك
[موسيقى]
فتخوف من فكره تشرذم او تقسيم الانترنت
انا لن استخدم مصطلح الحرب السيبرانيه ليس
الى هذا الحد ولكن طبعا هي معركه تجاريه
معركه
للحصول على النفوذ السياسي وصولا الى قطاع
الترفيه اذا اقحمت هوليبوت في ذلك
برايي هذا يقود مفهوم الانترنت باعتباره
فضاء لا حدود له
ومنصه يتم فيها تبادل الاراء ووجهه النظر
والافكار بكل حريه
والتشبيك وبناء علاقات من خلال اشخاص
افراد ثقافات عبر الحدود هذه رؤيه جميله
ونجحنا في انجازها وفي تحقيقها بالرغم من
انفسنا ان صح القول
ولدينا مثلا ويكيبيديا التي هي من اجمل
المصادر التي يمكن الاعتماد عليها في
العالم فهلا سيكون شيئا مؤسفا ان نرى هذه
الخطوه
الضخمه من اجل شر ذات هذا الانترنت هذا
الفضاء الواسع
ادم لا نريده
ونحن نضغط على
من اجل الى النظر الى حمايه البيانات
جزيلا دكتور بيتر مسك الخبير في امن
المعلومات والمحاضر في اداره الانترنت في
كليه الشؤون الدوليه والعامه في جامعه
كولومبيا كنت معنا من نيويورك شكرا جزيلا
للدكتور افضل اشرف استاذ الدراسات الامنيه
والعلاقات الدوليه في جامعه لابره
البريطانيه
وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام على متابعه هذه
الحلقه من برنامج مورا الخبر في الله
[موسيقى]